وصل الى الدوحه خمسه سجناء امريكيين كانوا
محتجازين في ايران تنفيذا لصفقه تبادل
سجناء بين واشنطن وطهران بواسطه قطريه
تتضمن الافراج عن خمسه سجناء ايرانيين في
الولايات المتحده اضافه الى الافراج عن
اموال ايرانيه واعربت قطر عن املها في ان
يفضي تنفيذ الاتفاق الى تفاهمات تمهد
للعوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات صفقه تبادل
الاسرى بين الولايات المتحده وايران والتي
تضمنت الافراج عن اموال ايرانيه مجمده في
كوريا الجنوبيه وايداعها في مصارف قطريه
وفي اي سياق اقليمي ودوليا جاءت على اي
نحو ستنعكس هذه الخطوه على مسار العلاقات
الايرانيه الامريكيه وهل ستفضي الى حوار
ومفاوضات جديده بين الجانبين حول قضايا
اخرى عالقه ابرزها الملف النووي الايراني
وكيف يتاثر الخليج وعموم المنطقه بمسار
العلاقات الامريكيه الايرانيه وتحولاتها
[موسيقى]
اختراق في جدار الخلافات الامريكيه
الايرانيه المستحكمه بوساطه قطريه شرعت كل
من واشنطن وطهران في تنفيذ اتفاق يتضمن
تبادلا للسجناء وافراج السلطات الامريكيه
عن اموال ايرانيه كانت مجمده لديها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن سمن الجهود التي ساعدت
في تسهيل اتفاق تبادل السجناء بين واشنطن
وطهران وفي ذات السياق قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
انه يتوجه بخالص الشكر لامير دوله قطر
وكبار المسؤولين القطريين لمساعدتهم في
التوصل للاتفاق وزير الدوله في وزاره
الخارجيه القطريه محمد الخليفي اعرب عن
امل دوله قطر في ان يفضي للتنفيذ الكامل
للاتفاق بين الولايات المتحده وايران الى
تفاهمات اكبر تشمل العوده الى خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه من جهتها
الخارجيه الايرانيه على لسان المتحدث
باسمها الى ان مساره تنفيذ الاتفاق لتبادل
السجناء والافراج عن الاموال الايرانيه
يتقدم بشكل جيد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا الدكتور عبدالله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت والدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه
الاولى في مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره
في الشؤون الايرانيه مرحبا بكما دكتور عبد
الله الشايجي باعتقادك ما هي العناصر
والعوامل التي امنت نجاح هذه الصفقه
التفاهمات ووساطه قطر في اعتقادي لعبت دور
جدا مهمه يعني هذه معادله نسميها رابح
رابح رابح ثلاثه اطراف رابحه بشكل كبير
المفاوضات كانت صعبه وسريه
منذ عام ونصف تقريبا خاضت ثمان جولات سريه
في قطر كان هناك ايضا قبول لقطر كوسيط
وهذا علامه تسجل لقطر بانها بالفعل نجحت
بان تكسب ود الطرفين الخصمين اللدودين منذ
الثوره الاسلاميه عام 79 وكذلك كان هناك
رغبه عند الرئيس بايدن بان يفي بوعوده كان
مرشح بانه لن يترك اي
رهينه او سجين امريكي في الخارج وعلى
راسها ايران وروسيا وطبعا سيسوقها الان في
حملتها الانتخابيه لان بايدن يعني الان
تحول الى مرشح اكثر منه رئيس وبدا يسوق
لذلك ايران ايضا في وضع اقتصادي صعب جدا
تريد ايضا ان تثبت بانها يمكنها ان تفلت
من العقوبات وتتخلص 40% نسبه تضخم العمله
الايرانيه شبه انهارت ولهذا السبب سيكون
يعني هذا رصيد لايران لان تبني عليه وكذلك
قطر اثبتت مرارا وتكرارا بانها لاعب مؤثر
يحظى بقبول الاطراف الدوليه والاقليميه
ولهذا السبب استضافت قطر هذه المفاوضات
ونجحت قطر وبطائره قطريه احضرت الخمسه
ايرانيين
امريكيين من اصول ايرانيه
تطلق امريكا صالح لاول مره هذا اختراق
كبير بالفعل هناك 6 مليارات دولار تحولت
من الارصده الايرانيه المجمده هنا نقطه
مهمه خلينا ناكد عليها لان الجمهوريين في
ومرشحين الحزب الجمهوري قاعدين ينتقدون
بايدن وادارته بانه دفع فديه هذه نقطه يجب
ان توضح بشكل كبير هذه ليست هذه اموال
ايرانيه مجمده
نعم مجمده سافرج عنها وذهبت الى جنوب
كوريا الجنوبيه الى سويسرا الى وصلت الى
الى الدوحه وسيتم انفاقها باشراف امريكا
وقطري على الامور الانسانيه والدواء
والغذاء فهذه صفقه كبيره قطر اثبتت مع
عمان ايضا وسويسرا الى حد ما اثبتت ان
بالفعل كان دليفري يعني واوصلت ما وعدت به
وقامت به خلال السنه كيف ينظر في طهران
الى هذه الصفقه وما تحقق من خلالها
بالنسبه لايران
الميزه الاساسيه بالنسبه لهذه الصفقه انها
مثمره بمعنى ان جولات المفاوضات الثمانيه
الجولات التي عقدت قد اتت بنتيجه لانه اذا
راينا مسار اعاده الاحياء التفاوض نجد انه
كان هناك جولات متعدده لكنها لم تكن تفضي
الى نتيجه كان يتم الوصول الى نقطه ما
يصبح استمرار التفاوض فيها غير مرغوب من
قبل الايرانيين او الطرف الامريكي ميزت
هذه المفاوضات انها مفاوضات مثمره
وبالنسبه للطرف الايراني فهذا ما تحقق على
هذا الصعيد هو خطوه ايجابيه دبلوماسيه
هناك نوع من الارتياح الدبلوماسي على هذا
الصعيد ايضا هناك نوع من الارتياح للدوري
القطري على هذا الصعيد هناك هامش من الثقه
في العلاقات
الايرانيه القطريه اثر بصوره واضحه على
مسار هذا التفاوض وعلى النتائج التي وصل
اليها ومن وجهه نظري ان اهميه هذه الصفقه
هي فيما سيبنى على هذه الصفقه بمعنى انه
النجاح في هذا الملف الجزئي في العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايران
وملفات العلاقه الشائكه كثيره وملفات
التفاوض كثيره واذا كان هناك تعثر في
موضوع احياء
الاتفاق النووي فهناك سلسله من الموضوعات
او الاتفاقيات الجزئيه التي القابله
للتفاوض والتي من الممكن ان تساهم في حللت
اشكاليه الاتفاق النووي لانه مع مرور
الزمن فنحن نقترب من من ازمه على صعيد
موضوع الاتفاق النووي خاصه انه في اكتوبر
القادم سيكون هناك انتهاء
حضر المفروض على ايران فيما يتعلق
بالجوانب العسكريه في هناك بند في الاتفاق
النووي و شيئا فشيئا نحن نقترب من نهايه
الاتفاق النووي لذلك هناك ازمه قادمه هذا
الاتفاق ربما يبنى عليه
امكانيات حلحله ازمات قادمه على صعيد
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
ماذا يعني ان يصف الرئيس الايراني اليوم
الافراج عن الامريكيين بانه عمل انساني
طبعا هو يحتاج هذا هذا الوصف في الداخل
الايراني ويحتاج لتوصيف الخطوه الايرانيه
على على هذا الصعيد لانه
ايضا الرئيس الايراني يتعامل مع داخل
ايرانيه يطرح اسئله باتجاه الكثير من
القضايا لكن الرئيس الايراني يعرفه وفريقه
يعرف انها كانت عمليه تفوضيه صعبه
وصلت الى هذه النتيجه بعد
سلسله من
الاجراءات والمفاوضات وكانت المفاوضات
تتوقف لبعض الوقت وكان هناك نوع من
الاشارات بانه تم التواصل الاتفاق ثم يتم
التراجع الى ان وصلنا الى هذه النتيجه هذه
النتيجه لم تكن
بهذه السهوله والا كان سيتم الافراج عنهم
بوقت مبكر وايضا عمليه تبادليه هناك عمليه
للتبادل تبادل السجناء وهذا التبادل الذي
جرى هو في حقيقته عمليه تفوضيه بكل ما
تحمل الكلمه من معنى دكتور عبد الله
الشايجي ايضا لو نظرنا الى الاتفاق من
المنظور الامريكي ما هو الانجاز ما الذي
تحقق
انجاز كبير لاداره بايدن يعني حقق ما وعد
به في حمله الانتخابيه بانه لن يترك اي
امريكي سجين بشكل يعني غير مقبول او بريء
وهذا طبعا ما كرره وزير الخارجيه اليوم
يعني
ابرياء الخمسه امريكيين من اصول ايرانيه
المحتجزين الذين كانوا محتجزين في طهران
بتهم التجسس ودعم دوله اجنبيه يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وابوالهم
صديقي يعني سماك نماذج نماذج
من ثمان سنوات محتجزه عاده من امريكا
ليزور اهله واحتجز وكذلك رجال اعمال ورجل
مختص بالبيئه يعني هؤلاء متهمين بتهمه
التجسس وهي تطحظها امريكا وكذلك سنسمع
منهم الان عندما هم متجهين الان الى
واشنطن بطائره اقلعت من الد هذه الليله
وهذا انجاز كبير في اعتقادي لبايدن طبعا
سيتم تسييس هذه القضيه او بدات منذ الشهر
الماضي انتقادات لاداره بايدن انها اعطت
النظام الارهابي الذي لا تزال تصنفه
امريكا بانها الدوله الاولى الراعيه
للارهاب في العالم اعطاه انجاز وهو يريد
ان يرضي ايضا الجناح المعارض
لاعطاء هذه الاموال لايران واللي يوضح بان
هذه ليست فديه كما يمثل كما يصورها
القياديين في الحزب الجمهوري في الكونغرس
وكذلك المرشحين الجنون هذه فلوس ايرانيه
تم احتجازها ببيع النفط الايراني لكوريا
الجنوبيه عندما فرض الرئيس ترامب في 2018
عقوبات صارمه على ايران تم تحويلها
بالعمله الكوريه الى السويسرا حولت الى
اليورو ثم الى الدولار ثم وصلت الى الدوحه
والصفقه كانت ان الدوحه تعلن للطرفين ان
استلمت المبلغ وتبدا المقايضه والتبادل
الرهائن او السجناء وهذا الذي حدث يعني
الان
قطر مع امريكا ستشرفان وهذا طبعا نقطه اكد
عليها الرئيس بايدن بانها ستشرفان على
انفاق هذه الاموال حتى لا تذهب لمشاريع
ايران التي تدعم الارهاب او حلفائها او
ازلامها او اذرعها في المنطقه يسكت به
الجمهوريين فهو انجاز يعني مهم جدا لاداره
بايدن وليسر
الخمسه ايرانيين
في سياق توضيح موضوع موضوع
انفاق هذه الاموال الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
يتحدث في مقابله صحفيه مع احدى المحطات
الامريكيه الاسبوع الماضي ويقول هذه
الاموال هي من حق الشع ب الايراني
وسيتم صرفها كيف ما يرتئي النظام في ايران
وضحي لنا هذه الجزئيه وكيفيه التعامل في
ايران مع هذه الاموال المفرد عنها
لكن اذا عدنا الى الاتفاق او ما تسرب عن
هذا الاتفاق
فهناك بنود في الاتفاق
الى اوجه التي سيتم صرف هذه المبالغ فيها
ولذلك هناك ايضا في الاتفاق ان قطر يعني
ستضمن الوجوه التي سيتم صرف فيها هذه
المبالغ المساله المهمه جدا على هذا
الصعيد انه هناك حاجه ايرانيه كبيره جدا
على صعيد الادويه واظن ان جزء كبير من من
هذه المبالغ ستوجه للحالات الصحيه في
ايران للاحتياجات الصحيه وهذا في ظن انه
قد بدا بالفعل
كما قلت الرئيس الايراني
يخاطب داخل الايراني في جزء كبير من هذه
التصريحات يخاطب
الفئه ستكون معارضه لهذا الاتفاق ايضا هو
يعرف بنود الاتفاق بالتاكيد وواحد من
بنودها
واحد من بنود هذا الاتفاق هي اوجه صرف هذه
المبالغ وكما قلت بان هذا المبلغ بشكل
اساسي سيوجه للقطاع الصحي بصوره اساسيه
يعني للاحتياجات الانسانيه كما ينص
الاتفاق اذا طيب دكتور عبد الله الشايجي
يعني ما حدث هو اختراق في هذه العلاقه بين
واشنطن وطهران ما الذي سيؤدي اليه هذا
الاختراق علما ان امتني بلينكن يقول اليوم
ان صفقه التبادل منفصله تماما عن العلاقات
بين واشنطن وطهران
صحيح يعني المفاوضات السريه كما قرانا
الان التي بدات في الدوحه قبل سنه ونصف
بدات بالاتفاق النووي العوده ايران
الاتفاق النووي الذي انسحبت منه اداره
ترامب في مايو 2018 بعد ثلاث سنوات من
توقيعه في اداره الرئيس اوباما
ولكنها في هناك تعثر الان ايران تقترب
بشكل كبير من رفع نسبه التخصيب اليورانيوم
الى من 60% الى 90% وهذا يقربها بشكل كبير
من ان تصل الى مستوى تخصيب العسكره
برنامجها النووي الاستخبارات الامريكيه
والجنرال مارك ميلي اللي هو رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه الامريكيه
الذي سيتقاعد في نهايه هذا الشهر اعلن في
مارس الماضي خبر صادم بان ايران يمكننا
خلال اسبوعين ان ترفع نسبه التخصيب الى 90
بالمئه وخلال اشهر
تقريبا قبل نهايه العام يمكنها ان تحصل
على اول قنبله نوويه اذا كان هناك في قرار
عند المرشد بان يذهب الى القوه النوويه
هذا محفز كان واعتقد ان الان سيكون هناك
في تركيز بعد بناء هذه الثقه يعني اهميه
هذه الصفقه الكبيره في اعتقادي انها تبني
الثقه وهذا ما لمح اليه
رئيس الوزراء القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن وكذلك محمد الخليفي وزير الدوله في
وزاره الخارجيه هذه الليله بان هذا يؤسس
او يبني تفاهمات قادمه وهذا يعني بان هناك
في محاولات الان قد تكون قد تجري او ستجري
لاجل التوصل الى نوع ما من اتفاق جزئي
نووي من اجل ان يكون هناك على مطلع اذا
عاد الرئيس بايدن انتخب في نوفمبر قبل ذلك
ان يحقق انج او ان يختم رئاسته اذا فاز
بجوله بولايه ثانيه بانجاز تاريخي مثل
سلفه الرئيس
اوباما الذي كان هو نائبه بانه توصل
اتفاقنا في 2015 في اخر سنه له في البيت
الابيض يعني هذه اهميه هذا الاتفاق يؤسس
والى ارضيه يمكن ان يبنى عليها الثقه
وتفاهمات من اجل اختراق اخر قد نسمع عنه
خلال الاشهر القادمه في مفاوضات سريه
توصل الى نوعا ما من تفاهمات تؤدي الى
عوده ايران لاتفاق نووي يتفق عليه من
الطرفين لان اتفاق النووي هذا خلال الاشهر
القادمه سينتهي جزءا منه وبعد سنتين
سينتهي الجزء الاخر في تحديات وبعد ان
يملك الكثير من الاوراق ليروجك رئيس دوله
ورجل دوله مهم في حملته الانتخابيه على ما
يبدو ضد ترامب في 20 24
المعطيات لاسيما موضوع الانتخابات
الامريكيه وموضوع الاستحقاقات المتعلقه
بالاتفاق النووي الايراني دكتوره فاطمه هل
هناك استعداد لدى ظهران في هذه المرحله
للانتقال الى ما هو ابعد من هذه الصفقه
بالبناء عليها الى ما هو ابعد
يحدث تغيير لذلك الحل هو اختراقات جزئيه
ملفات جزئيه الى ان يتم التوصل الى ما
يمكن ان نسميه اتفاق شامل وهذا من وجهه
نظري ما زال بعيدا قبل وان كان هذا ما زال
بعيدا قريبين اكثر من كيفيه ربما انعكاس
هذه الصفقه التي جرت اليوم هذا الاختراق
كما سمي في هذه العلاقه انعكاس على مجمل
المنطقه
والملفات في المنطقه لصيام تلك التي تشهد
مواجهه غير معلنه ايرانيه امريكيه
نعم هو
ما تحقق من وجهه نظري هو بناء هامش من
الثقه من الممكن ان يبنى عليه في هذه
المساله نحن ننظر الى اكثر من جانب منها
العلاقات الايرانيه القطريه والتي شهدت
تطورا ملحوظا ومهما خلال السنوات الماضيه
وهناك مساله تتعلق بالعلاقات الايرانيه
الامريكيه وهي علاقات معقده تركت على مدى
العقود الماضيه تاثيرات
مباشره وغير مباشره على مجمل
ملفات المنطقه ملفات المنطقه كثيره ومعقده
من ملف سوريا في العراق في اليمن وغيرها
من الملفات لذلك فالملفات الجزئيه التي من
الممكن ان يتم الحديث بشانها كثيره ومهمه
خاصه وان القرار السياسي الايراني الى
الان يرفض التفاوض المباشر مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى ان الوساطه
القطريه او الاستضافه القطريه ما زالت
مؤهله لان تفتح ملفات جزئيه مهمه في
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وايران وهي كما قلت علاقات معقده ومؤثره
على مجمل السياسات في المنطقه والملفات
المنطقه الملفات الاقليميه انا من وجهه
نظري من الممكن ان يحدث اختراقات فيها
يعني على بشكل ربما يكون مشابه ولا يمكن
ان نفصل ان نفكك هذه الملفات وان كان هناك
نوع من التفكيك الفعلي لكنها ملفات يعني
توصل الى بعضها وتفتح هذا الملف من الممكن
هذا الاختراق من الممكن ان يفتح على ملفات
اخرى لقد تكون اسهل من الممكن التفاوض
بشانها دكتور عبد الله لو نظرنا الى ما
حدث اليوم في السياق الاقليمي كيف يمكن
تقييمه وكيف يمكن ان ينعكس على دول
المنطقه
هذا سؤال مهم
طبعا انا اعتقد في انفراجات قادمه واضح
جدا ان هناك في تفاهمات ثلاثيه خليجيه
ايرانيه امريكيه التقارب السعودي الايراني
كان من هذه الثمرات التهدئه في الحوثيين
في اليمن يعني سنه الان اكتوبر القادم راح
يكون سنه منذ ان انتهت الهدنه الرسميه دون
ان يحدث اي اعتداء على السعوديه زياره
الوفد الحوثي الى الرياض زياره مهمه قبل
ايام اعتقد هذه ايضا تنعكس على حلفاء
واذرع ايران في المنطقه منذ مارس الماضي
لم تشن
الفصائل المواليه لايران والمدعومه من
ايران اي هجمات على القوات الامريكيه في
العراق وفي سوريا اعتقد هذه التهدئه
ستنعكس ايضا على دي اسكليشن كما يسمى خفض
التوتر بين لبنان حزب الله واسرائيل هناك
من يروج منذ فتره بان هناك حرب رئيس تقع
في تصعيد وامريكا ترسل جيوش وقوات كل هذا
كلام فاضي وكل قرقعه لا معنى لها امريكا
بالفعل ارسلت ثلاثه الاف عسكري في
الربيع الماضي ولكن هذه كما تسميه امريكا
للرد على هناك اجواء تهدئه صحيحه وحقيقيه
وهذا الاتفاق وهذا الاختراق وهذه الصفقه
اليوم اتت لتؤكد ذلك واننا نبتعد عن قرقعه
طبول
الحرب الوهميه التي يروج لها البعض لا
افهم لماذا ونقترب من نوع من التهدئه التي
الجميع سيستفيد منها بسبب هذه التقارب
والتفاهمات والتقارب والتي نامل ان تتوج
بايضا مفاوضات لاتفاق نووي يهدئ الاوضاع
ويبعدنا عن التصعيد الذي لا احد يريده
شكرا جزيلا لكما الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
والدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى
في مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في
الشؤون الايرانيه الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]